An optional piece of software is something called launchpad central at www.launchpadcentral.com.
The launchpad central allows you to share your work, your customer discovery narrative,
what's you're doing outside the building with mentors and instructors and everybody else.
Some of you might think, "Well, I don't want to share what I'm doing," but it's not sharing your IP
or your great ideas--it's actually sharing what you found out in testing your hypothesis
and it allows others to comment in real time.
So in fact, you won't have to sit alone thinking about "Am I on the right path
or is this the right strategy, etc."
The launchpad central comes with the startup weekend program,
which are available to anybody else here at launchpadcentral.com.
It is not required for this class but is a great resource if you're interested.